rejoignez-moi sur patronne pour accéder
à l'ensemble de mon contenu inédit des
épisodes spéciaux des cours en visio des
apérophilos un moyen simple de soutenir
mon travail tout en vous donnant matière
à penser je vous attends sur pas créole
le lien est dans la description
bonjour à tous
aujourd'hui on va parler de Pierre
Bourdieu
Pierre Bourdieu est un sociologue
français du 20e siècle c'est même le
sociologue français du XXe siècle l'un
des plus cités et des plus félicités
pour son œuvre
son influence dans le champ des sciences
sociales a été prépondérante d'autant
qu'à la fin de sa vie il est mort en
2002 bon Dieu fut également un
intellectuel engagé
engagé dans les mouvements sociaux
engagés pour l'émergence d'une gauche
qui soit vraiment de gauche
et encore aujourd'hui bon Dieu est
souvent cité en référence dans les
milieux militants progressistes en
particulier pour ces travaux sur la
domination masculine publiée en 1998 ou
encore pour son concept de violence
symbolique dont on parlera dans cet
épisode
l'idée de violence symbolique étant un
aspect et une préfiguration de ce qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui l'oppression
systémique à savoir une violence qui est
inscrite dans les structures de la
société et qui s'exerce de manière
invisible
la grande contribution de Bourdieu c'est
d'avoir montré que le pouvoir pouvait
s'exercer sans la contrainte ou en tout
cas sans la contrainte physique
la domination n'est pas physique elle
est symbolique
autrement dit elle est dans nos
représentations
et dans la mesure où nos représentations
déterminent notre comportement la
domination symbolique s'exerce jusque
dans notre corps
elle est intériorisée
en ce sens la vision Bourdieu c'est une
étape supplémentaire par rapport à la
vision de la Boétie
pour la Boétie nous sommes dans la
servitude volontaire
pour Bourdieu nous sommes dans la
servitude inconsciente
dans la servitude imperceptible
Bourdieu disait d'ailleurs qu'il n'y
avait de science que du cachet
ce qui est caché c'est ça qui demande à
être dévoilé
ce qui est visible ouvertement visible
il y a pas grand chose à en dire
donc pour résumer Bourdieu est un
sociologue qui fait l'analyse des
structures de la domination
des structures invisibles voire
inconscientes de la domination
et dans la contribution fut déterminante
dans la compréhension des mécanismes du
pouvoir contemporain
alors pour vous initier à la pensée de
Bourdieu j'ai décidé de partir d'un
autre de ces grands concepts un concept
qui finalement enveloppe tous les autres
à savoir le concept de reproduction
au bon Dieu ce qui fait que la
domination se maintient et qui la rend
si difficile à combattre c'est ce
phénomène de la reproduction
alors qu'est-ce que Bourdieu appelle la
reproduction
la reproduction c'est le fait que les
inégalités sociales c'est-à-dire la
situation dans la hiérarchie sociale
se perpétue par transmission familiale
autrement dit que l'on
hérite d'une position de dominant ou de
dominer
et que donc l'idée de mobilité sociale
l'idée d'ascension sociale est un mythe
pour Bourdieu la méritocratie
c'est-à-dire y déclare réussite
dépendrait seulement de nos efforts
c'est une illusion
mais c'est une illusion dont les
dominants ont besoin pour pouvoir
légitimer leur statut de dominant
il a toute une analyse de la
légitimation chez Bourdieu le fait que
les dominants justifient leur statut de
dominant par une culture dominante
par un mode de pensée dominant
et donc si on vous fait croire que la
société est fondée sur le mérite et que
vous vous retrouvez en position de
dominer vous allez vous dire c'est ma
faute
je n'ai pas assez travaillé
et là c'est exactement ça que veulent
les dominants
ils veulent que les dominer croient dans
la justesse de leur statut de dominer
dans sa justesse et dans sa justice
le mérite c'est un concept qui vient
légitimer la situation des dominants et
donc la situation des dominés
à cela la réponse de Bourdieu est sans
appel non
il n'est pas juste que les dominés soit
dominés
ce n'est pas l'absence de mérite la
cause de leur statut de dominée la cause
de leur statut de dominée c'est le
phénomène sociologique de la
reproduction
à savoir que la position d'un individu
dans l'appareil de domination et le
résultat d'un héritage
c'est le résultat des structures de la
domination
c'est le résultat d'un déterminisme
social
exemple de déterminisme social
si vos parents sont cadres vous avez
plus de chance de devenir cadre que si
vos parents sont ouvriers
si vos parents ont un réseau social et
professionnel important vous avez plus
de chances d'hériter de ce même réseau
que si vos parents n'en ont pas
ça paraît logique
ça semble presque une banalité
et oui mais c'est une banalité
recouverte par le mythe de la
méritocratie
c'est une banalité qui se heurte au
discours officiel sur l'égalité des
chances
il n'y a pas d'égalité des chances
il y a des mécanismes
des mécanismes collectifs des mécanismes
structurels et l'individu qui parvient à
s'extraire de ces mécanismes ne
représente pas la règle
il représente l'exception à la règle
la sociologie c'est l'étude du réel
au-delà du discours officiel sur le réel
c'est la volonté de comprendre comment
les choses sont réellement structurées
dans la société
et non pas comment le pouvoir prétend
qu'elles sont structurées
donc dire que les positions sociales se
transmettent de génération en génération
c'est peut-être énoncé une banalité mais
c'est dénoncé une banalité signifiante
signifiante parce qu'elle montre que les
phénomènes sociaux ne sont pas le
résultat du hasard
parce qu'elles montrent que le pouvoir a
un intérêt à propager un discours
méritocratique pour asseoir et légitimer
sa domination
et signifiant parce qu'elle montre que
l'individu n'est pas libre
si l'individu était libre il pourrait
échapper aux déterminisme social
il pourrait comme dirait Sartre se faire
tel qu'il se veut
mais on ne se fait pas tel qu'on se veut
on se fait-elle qu'on se peut
on se fait tel que nos moyens nous
permettent de nous faire
et ses moyens on les a si on en hérite
on les a pas si on en hérite pas
Bourdieu s'opposer à Sartre
il voyait dans l'existentialisme
sartrien l'expression du naïveté
sociologique
l'idée que l'individu pourrait
s'affranchir des structures
d'ailleurs bourvieux disait lui-même
qu'il faudrait faire la sociologie des
partisans de la liberté
car lors on pourrait s'apercevoir que
ceux qui croient dans le concept de
liberté sont souvent ceux qui sont en
position de pouvoir y croire
ce sont les dominants qui croient dans
la liberté
qui croit ou qui veulent que nous y
croyons
pour rendre tenir l'idée que si on ne
réussit pas c'est de notre faute
pour Bourdieu si l'individu ne peut pas
être libre c'est parce qu'il ne choisit
pas les cartes avec lesquelles il va
jouer
or ce qu'il va jouer dépend directement
des cartes qu'il a entre les mains
si vous naissez dans une famille
bourgeoise vous aurez accès à toute une
série d'avantages
à toute une série de privilèges auquel
vous n'auriez pas eu accès si vous étiez
né dans une famille ouvrière
voyagez
intégrer une grande école privée
consacrée 100% de votre temps à vos
études sans avoir besoin de travailler à
côté
et tout ça va évidemment participer à
votre intégration dans les structures
dominantes
on a tous connu ça quand on était au
collège
l'élève qui fait son stage dans
l'entreprise de son père
ou d'un ami de son père
le réseau
donc la reproduction ce n'est finalement
rien d'autre que la théorisation d'un
système d'habitude sociale grâce auquel
le système de domination perdure
et ses habitudes sociales ces mécanismes
sociaux dépassent très largement en
puissance et en influence le prétendu
mérite individuel du discours
institutionnel
la position dans l'appareil de
domination ne dépend pas seulement de
nos efforts de notre travail ni même de
notre intelligence
elle dépend d'abord des structures dont
nous avons
hérité
Bourdieu prend l'exemple de l'école
d'ailleurs son livre intitulé la
reproduction publiée en 1970 a pour
sujet central l'éducation
et la manière dont l'école reproduit
c'est-à-dire perpétue les hiérarchies
sociales qui sont à l'oeuvre à
l'extérieur de l'école
donc contrairement à ce qu'on entend
souvent dire l'école n'est pas détachée
du monde extérieur
elle n'est pas préserver des inégalités
elle en est au contraire le principal
agent de perpétuation
alors qu'on soit bien d'accord
l'école telle qu'on la connaît c'est à
dire l'école laïque obligatoire et
gratuite
constitué évidemment un progrès social
mais c'est un progrès qui dissimule une
réalité beaucoup moins noble
à savoir que l'école reproduit les
inégalités
elle reproduit les structures de la
domination
l'école n'est pas le lieu de l'égalité
des chances
elle est le lieu de la division des
chances
divisions des chances au sens où les
élèves ont les chances qui correspondent
à la position sociale de leurs parents
position sociale élevée égale
probabilité élevée de réussir son
parcours scolaire
pour une raison simple qui est que la
culture scolaire la culture enseignée et
valorisée dans nos écoles c'est la
culture des dominants
c'est la culture produite par les
dominants et c'est la culture reconnue
par les dominants
seuls les dominants sont en situation
d'imposer leur culture comme culture
dominante
et donc le fait que la culture scolaire
soit la culture des dominants ça ne peut
que favoriser les élèves dont les
parents font eux-mêmes partie des
classes dominantes
les élèves dont les parents sont
habitués à aller au théâtre
à aller au musée
les élèves dont les parents parlent
plusieurs langues
qui le soir à table parle de la dernière
découverte scientifique
ou de l'actualité internationale
autrement dit les élèves dont les
parents possèdent un capital culturel
parce que c'est ce capital culturel qui
détermine et définit le taux de réussite
à l'école
plus vous avez baigné étant enfant dans
un milieu cultivé c'est à dire dans un
milieu ayant accès à la culture
plus vous avez mécaniquement de chance
de réussir votre parcours scolaire
le fait de baigner dans un monde cultivé
rend l'élève à l'aise dans l'univers
scolaire
salut les familier
ce que montre pour Dieu c'est que la
réussite scolaire se joue moins à
l'école qu'à l'extérieur de l'école
à la maison
un élève dont les parents ont un niveau
bac + 5 c'est un élève à qui les parents
pourront réexpliquer comment on pose une
multiplication
ou pourquoi 1789 est une date à retenir
l'élève des classes dominantes non
seulement et plus familier avec les
références du professeur mais en plus il
pourra bénéficier à la maison d'une
reformulation de l'enseignement
donc on n'a pas à faire à une réduction
des inégalités
on a affaire à une amplification des
inégalités
les enfants issus des catégories
dominantes Bourdieu les appelle les
héritiers
les enfants issus des catégories
socialement défavorisées pour Dieu les
appelle les déshérités
de quoi héritent les héritiers
ils héritent d'un capital
d'un capital symbolique
capital symbolique qui inclut le capital
économique le capital culturel et le
capital social
le capital économique c'est l'argent
le capital culturel c'est la
connaissance
le capital social c'est le réseau
argent connaissance réseau
voilà les trois formes de capital dont
les enfants ont des classes favorisées
héritent
et si Bourdieu empreinte ici au
vocabulaire de l'économie ce n'est pas
pour rien
c'est pour souligner le fait que le
capital c'est l'ensemble des ressources
par lesquelles on fait fructifier ce
capital
le capital rapporte au capital
plus vous avez de connaissances plus
vous allez avoir de facilité à faire
augmenter ses connaissances
que vous avez de réseau plus vous allez
avoir de facilité à faire augmenter ce
réseau
c'est comme avec l'argent
démarrer sa vie avec 100.000 euros sur
son compte ou avec 10 euros c'est pas
pareil
à l'arrivée ça fait une grosse
différence
et on sait que le capital ne
s'additionne pas
il se multiplie
donc quand un enfant va à l'école ce
qu'on lui demande c'est qu'à la fin du
trimestre ce soit lui qui est le plus
grand capital
c'est ça que ça veut dire être le
premier de sa classe
être le premier de sa promo
c'est avoir le score le plus élevé au
compteur
relevé de compte relevés de notes
soldes positif au dessus de la moyenne
solde négatif en dessous de la moyenne
mais sauf que tout le monde ne rentre
pas dans la compétition avec le même
capital de départ
alors oui il y a ceux qui ont un petit
capital et qui vont réussir à le faire
augmenter
comme il y a ceux qui ont un grand
capital et qui vont se laisser porter
ce dont on dit justement qu'ils ont des
facilités
et qui se repose sur ses facilités
donc la reproduction c'est le processus
par lequel on hérite de la position
sociale de ses parents en héritant de
leur capitale symbolique
notre place dans la société n'est pas
définie par nos efforts ou par notre
liberté
elle est définie par notre héritage
les héritiers seront demain les
dominants et les déshérités seront
demain les dominés
alors histoire de souffler un peu
j'aimerais quand même faire une
parenthèse sur la sociologie de Bourdieu
et plus particulièrement sur son
approche philosophique de la société
Bourdieu à une formation de philosophes
c'est un philosophe qui a cheminé vers
la science d'ailleurs il tenait beaucoup
à affirmer la valeur scientifique de ces
travaux
et donc en tant que philosophe il a une
certaine vision du monde
et une certaine vision de la société
pour Bourdieu la société n'est pas à
proprement parler faite d'individus
elle est d'abord faite de structure
des structures qui vont se refléter et
se reproduire à travers le comportement
des individus
dans la sociologie de Bourdieu
l'individu c'est une partie d'un système
et c'est ce qui fait que la sociologie
de Bourdieu a souvent été qualifié de
déterministes
parce qu'elle réfute l'idée que les
individus pourraient s'affranchir des
structures sociales
sauf à la marche bien sûr
alors vous allez me dire est-ce que ça
c'est pas le propre de la sociologie
elle-même
de considérer la société comme un
système et d'envisager les comportements
individuels comme structuré plutôt que
comme structurant
oui et non
oui non parce qu'en sociologie il y a
plusieurs courants
pour schématiser il y a d'un côté le
courant holiste c'est-à-dire les
sociologues qui considèrent la société
comme un tout c'est le courant auquel
appartient pour Dieu
et il y a d'un autre côté le courant
individualiste c'est à dire les
sociologues qui voient la société comme
le résultat de la conjonction d'action
individuelles
c'était par exemple la conception de
Raymond Boudon
le concurrent individualiste si j'ose
dire le pire Bourdieu
mais il est vrai qu'à l'origine la
sociologie a plutôt une approche holiste
des phénomènes sociaux
le premier à avoir posé les fondements
de cette approche en Europe c'est Émile
Durkheim
et Bourdieu considère d'ailleurs comme
l'un de ses maîtres
et que disait
il disait que les faisceaux étaient
tirésductibles à la somme des faits
individuels
ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que ce ne sont pas tant les
individus qui font le collectif que le
collectif qui fait les individus
autrement dit les individus sont d'abord
le reflet du milieu auquel ils
appartiennent
et sa philosophiquement c'est pas neutre
quand je dis c'est pas notre je veux
dire on peut ne pas être d'accord avec
ça
mais il y a des faits des faits
mesurable
ce qu'on appelle des statistiques
et les statistiques tombent à montrer
que sociologiquement il y a des
tendances
il y a des constantes
que certes il existe des cas
particuliers ce qu'on pourra appeler des
accidents sociologiques
mais que dans l'ensemble les individus
appartenant à un groupe social
se comporte conformément aux modalités
de ce groupe social
et bien pour le coup Pierre Bourdieu est
lui-même un accident sociologique
une exception à la règle mais qui
pourtant avec son concept de
reproduction à théoriser les structures
de cette règle
pour Dieu est originaire du Béarn son
père est un ancien paysan devenu facteur
donc autant dire milieu populaire
il est reçu à l'École normale supérieure
où on se moque de lui pour son accent
pyrénéen
mais à force de travail il finit par
devenir professeur à l'École des hautes
études en sciences sociales
jusqu'à devenir plus tard professeur au
Collège de France et un intellectuel
reconnu dans le monde entier
exemple s'il en est d'ascension sociale
selon sa propre terminologie Bourdieu et
un miraculé
un rescapé de la reproduction
pour Dieu c'est un peu l'antithèse de
Daniel Pennac l'écrivain
les nains disaient je viens d'un milieu
aisé r polytechnicien
bibliothèque à la maison parents aimant
et pourtant je suis un cancre
j'ai été sociologiquement programmé pour
réussir et pourtant j'échoue
c'est la théorie de la reproduction
était vraie je ne devrais pas échouer
je devrais faire partie de l'élite
puisque j'en viens
et à contrario Bourdieu aurait dû finir
sur une voie de garage
fils de paysan loin du monde parisien
loin des conférences et des centres
culturels
donc c'est bien la preuve qu'il y a dans
certains parcours individuels des
facteurs qui échappent à l'œil du
sociologue
et que les corps conscients ne se
comportent pas de manière aussi
prédictible que les corps physique
et du coup la question épistémologique
qu'on ne peut pas ne pas se poser c'est
qu'en est-il du point de vue du
sociologue
qu'en est-il de l'influence de la
position sociale de celui qui analyse
l'organisation des positions sociales
le sociologue peut-il se défaire de sa
propre sociologie
c'est évidemment un reproche qui a été
adressé à Bourdieu à savoir le fait
qu'il critique la domination culturelle
tout en étant devenu lui-même un maillon
de cette domination culturelle
pour ne pas dire l'un de ces éléments
les plus éminents
j'aimerais récemment quelque chose qui
m'a frappé une conférence de Gisèle
Sapiro intitulé penser la domination
avec Pierre Bourdieu
Gisèle Sapiro toute contente de nous
dire en conclusion de sa conférence
que Bourdieu faisait partie des
sociologues les plus cités et les plus
reconnues dans le monde après nous avoir
expliqué pendant une heure que c'était
justement ça la domination culturelle
le prestige
des élites qui s'autocoopte qui
s'autochtracule
et qui se faisant se reproduisent entre
elles
bon Dieu critique la domination
culturelle il critique la domination par
le langage notamment à l'école
le fait que les enfants des classes
dominer soit dans une situation de
pauvreté linguistique
mais il nous explique ça avec un phrasé
tellement compliqué que même les autres
sociologues ont du mal à le comprendre
comme le disait en plaisantant son ami
Roger Chartier pour Dieu écrit pour ceux
qui ne peuvent pas le lire
et c'est vrai
et le plus ironique c'est que la
définition qu'il donne de la violence
symbolique est une illustration parfaite
de ce qu'est la violence symbolique
c'est-à-dire une définition qui
nécessite de posséder des outils
linguistiques que les personnes des
classes défavorisées ne possèdent pas
je cite la violence symbolique et cette
coercition qui ne s'institue que par
l'intermédiaire de l'adhésion que le
dominé ne peut manquer d'accorder aux
dominants lorsqu'ils ne dispose pour le
penser et pour se penser ou mieux pour
penser sa relation avec lui que
d'instruments de connaissances qu'il a
avec lui et qui n'étant que la forme
incorporée de la structure de la
relation de domination font apparaître
cette relation comme naturelle ou en
d'autres termes lorsque les chaînes
qu'il mettent en œuvre pour se percevoir
et s'apprécier ou pour apercevoir et
apprécier les dominants sont le produit
de l'incorporation des classements ainsi
naturalisées dont son être social est le
produit fin de citation
on a déjà vu plus accessible
alors est-ce qu'en tant que déshérité
bon Dieu ne serait pas lui-même en quête
de la légitimité qui dénonce
une sorte de surcompensation
linguistique pour faire reconnaître par
le monde universitaire une situation
d'inégalité qu'il veut combattre
faire partie des dominants pour pouvoir
mieux défendre les dominés
c'est possible
d'ailleurs bon Dieu lui-même avait
commencé une auto-analyse
une auto-analyse publiée deux ans après
sa mort dans laquelle il exprime le fait
qu'il a conscience de ses déterminations
sociologiques
et du fait que ces origines béarnaises
sont sans doute à l'origine de son
tempérament combatif
d'ailleurs dans un documentaire que
Pierre Carl lui a consacré pour Dieu
dira lui-même que la sociologie est un
sport de combat
donc Bourdieu n'est pas aveugle à ses
propres déterminations sociologiques
il n'est pas aveugle à ce que son
environnement social et culturel a fait
de lui
il n'est pas aveugle à son habitude
l'habitude c'est l'ensemble des
dispositions
acquises par l'individu au cours de ces
interactions sociales et qui définissent
sa manière d'être
sa manière de parler sa manière de se
tenir sa manière de s'habiller
l'habitude c'est ce que notre milieu
nous fait devenir en tant qu'individu
c'est l'incorporation de la structure de
notre milieu social en nous
et quand je dis incorporation il faut
l'entendre au sens littéral
incorporer c'est mettre dans un corps
c'est intégrer dans son corps les
mécanismes de comportement propre à
notre classe sociale
on l'a dit tout à l'heure la domination
ne s'exerce pas par la contrainte
physique
elle s'exerce par les représentations et
par le fait que les individus
intériorisent dans leur corps les
mécanismes de la domination
et des intériorisent au point de finir
par les considérer comme légitime
comme justifier
comme naturel
Marx en avait déjà parlé ça s'appelle
l'aliénation
la fausse conscience
la conscience qui fait qu'on va
justifier nous-mêmes notre statut de
dominer
le mauvais élève qui a intériorisé le
fait non pas qu'il a des difficultés
inhérentes à sa situation sociologique
mais qu'il est nul
donc l'habitude on le reproduit sans en
être conscient
habitus habitude habitude habiter on se
confond avec son habitude
on se confond avec les structures de
notre environnement
et même quand on cherche à corriger son
habitude même quand on cherche à le
modifier ou à le dissimuler il refait
toujours surface en situation de stress
un accent qui revient quand on s'énerve
un vocabulaire qu'on reprend quand on
revoit un vieil ami
chasser l'habitude il revient au galop
ce que nous dit Bourdieu c'est que la
reproduction est aussi une affaire de
comportement
à chaque fois qu'on se comporte selon
l'habitude propre à notre classe sociale
on reproduit à l'échelle individuel les
structures de notre classe sociale
et se faisant on s'y maintient
on s'y maintient et on y maintient ce
avec qui on interagit
la domination n'est pas seulement une
affaire d'existence de structure
elle est une affaire de reproduction des
structures
la domination
c'est vivant
je cite
tout action pédagogique est
objectivement une violence symbolique en
tant qu'imposition par un pouvoir
arbitraire d'un arbitraire culturel dans
une formation sociale déterminée le
travail pédagogique par lequel
s'accomplit l'action pédagogique
dominante a toujours une fonction de
maintien de l'ordre c'est-à-dire de
reproduction de la structure des
rapports de force entre les groupes ou
classes en tant quittant soit par
l'incultation soit par l'exclusion
imposée aux membres des groupes ou
classes dominés la reconnaissance de la
légitimité de la culture dominante et à
leur faire intérioriser dans une mesure
variable des disciplines et des censures
qui ne servent jamais aussi bien les
intérêts matériels ou symboliques des
groupes ou classes dominants que
lorsqu'elles prennent la forme de
l'autodiscipline et de l'autocensure
tout système d'enseignement
institutionnalisé doit les
caractéristiques spécifiques de sa
structure et de son fonctionnement au
fait qu'il lui faut produire et
reproduire par les moyens propres de
l'institution
conditions institutionnelles dont
l'existence et la persistance sont
nécessaires tant à l'exercice de sa
fonction de reproduction d'un arbitraire
culturel dont il n'est pas le producteur
et dont la reproduction contribue à la
reproduction des rapports entre les
groupes ou les classes on comprend que
pour s'acquitter complètement de cette
fonction de conservation sociale le
système scolaire doivent présenter la
minute de vérité de l'examen comme sa
vérité l'élimination soumise au
solnormes de l'équitté scolaire et par
la formellement irréprochable qu'il
opère et assume dissimule
l'accomplissement de la fonction du
système scolaire en obtubilant par
l'opposition entre les reçus et les
refusés la relation entre les candidats
et tous ceux que le système a exclu des
facto du nombre des candidats et en
dissimulant par là les liens entre le
système scolaire et la structure des
rapports de classe si tout opération de
sélection a toujours indissociablement
pour effet de contrôler des
qualifications techniques par référence
aux du marché du travail et de créer des
qualités sociales par référence à la
structure des rapports de classe que le
système d'enseignement contribue à
perpétuer bref si l'école détient à la
fois une fonction technique de
production et d'attestation des
capacités et une fonction sociale de
conservation et de consécration du
pouvoir et des privilèges on comprend
que les sociétés modernes fournissent au
système d'enseignement des occasions
multipliées d'exercer son pouvoir de
transmuer des avantages sociaux en
avantage scolaire eux-mêmes
reconvertibles en avantage sociaux parce
qu'elle lui permette de présenter des
préalables scolaires donc implicitement
sociaux comme des pré-requisites
techniques de l'exercice d'une
profession c'est en effet à son
autonomie relative que le système
d'enseignement traditionnel doit de
pouvoir apporter une contribution
spécifique à la reproduction de la
structure des rapports de classe
puisqu'il lui suffit d'obéir à ses
règles propres pour obéir du même coup
et comme par surcroît aux impératifs
externes qui définissent sa fonction de
légitimation de l'ordre établi
c'est-à-dire pour remplir simultanément
sa fonction sociale de reproduction des
rapports de classe en assurant la
transmission héréditaire du capital
culturel et sa fonction idéologique de
dissimulation de cette fonction en
accréditant l'illusion de son autonomie
absolue
la critique de la domination est
toujours à double tranchant
si elle est trop radicale
elle ne passe pas le pH de
l'institutionnalisation
et elle se condamne à n'être connu que
d'un petit cercle d'initié
si elle est trop douce trop poli
elle n’attend pas son but
qui est la transformation de la société
mais peut-être faisons-nous peser sur
les penseurs critiques
une charge trop lourde
une mission trop lourde
celle de nous guider
alors qu'ils sont déjà en train de nous
éclairer
celle de nous tenir la main
pour nous emmener vers des lendemains
meilleurs
alors qu'ils sont déjà en train de nous
donner la direction
au fond qu'attendons-nous des penseurs
critiques
qu'ils pensent
qu'ils analysent
qu'ils dévoilent
ou qui nous disent quoi faire
ce n'est pas eux nous dire quoi faire
car alors on sortirait d'une situation
de soumission pour aussitôt se placer
dans une autre situation de soumission
les dominés ne sont pas responsables de
leur situation
mais ils sont responsables de l'accepter
quant à leur est dévoilé
je vous remercie
[Musique]